Nerds love puzzles, especially the kind
you can solve in public to demonstrate
your massive intellect. In Wizards, they
know their audience. Crafting nerd bait
is practically their specialty. Just
take a janky design from a summer
intern, add a single rulebreaking line
of text, toss it out, and watch the
nerds swarm to it. How well does it
play? Doesn't matter. That's their
problem to solve. Just look at them one
by one by one. It's so predict. Hold up.
What am I doing there? Hello everyone.
This is Jyn with Next Level Commander
and I am very smart, but others in my
play group are having trouble seeing it
partly because of my previous hair
apparent decks. Not quite doing what I
wanted. Balin feels more like a combo
deck or nothing. Arabella and Finineas
are explosive but a bit too fragile. All
these top commanders are missing
something. I felt something mysterious
hovering at the edge of my perception
when I searched for it. But when I close
my eyes, I Oh, yeah. It It's just black.
Here, a parent needs black. Simple as
that. Aristocrats is the best way, not
close. But why am I bringing this up
now? I'm glad you asked. Well, because
I'm also a bit of an expert in the
workings of the interwebs, algorithms,
trends, and all that. In simpler terms,
here is the pulse of the internet, and
here's my finger. Lauren Eclipse is the
next hot topic, and I'm always on top of
those. And this set happens to include
possibly the best hair apparent
commander. The one I've been waiting
for, Erdo, carrier of dawn. And the flip
side, Iselu, carrier of Twilight. Erdo.
Her hairdo. No way. This is a
coincidence. If that isn't on the nose
enough for you, just take a look at the
abilities. The front side is explosive
and the backside provides resilience.
So, our commander does pretty much
everything. With commanders like this,
we just need to find their weaknesses,
address that, and they'll take care of
the game. The first problem with Erdo is
the cost. It's actually pretty expensive
at five mana, and it's probably a
removal magnet because our opponents are
jealous. So, what do we do? You're
expecting me to say protection spells,
aren't you? Not this time. I'm a man
full of surprises. Subscribe for more.
But this time, we are not dedicating too
many card slots to keeping our commander
around because our deck is a perfectly
functional aristocrat's shell. Erdo just
takes it over the top. We do want a
decent amount of RAM though to get Erdo
out as early as possible. Been living in
my car for two weeks now to buy the new
soul stone. Nothing else really worth
addressing here. Nothing too special
except for maybe patchwork banner I
guess cuz we do plan to attack once in a
while. Another weakness we need to
address is gas. Erdo the front side
allows us to convoke into convoke into
more convoke, but we need to keep the
gas flowing. So I maxed out on card
draw. Turns out black can do anything as
long as you feed bunnies into the
machine. We are prioritizing card draw
in creature form because they can also
be convoked out. We actually get so many
bunnies once we get the train rolling
that sandstone Oracle is a perfectly
reasonable inclusion. I was actually
this close to tossing in some coslex as
well. Might still try them if the deck
turns out to be explosive enough, but
for now the rule of thumb is creatures
with exactly one black pip. Those are
ideal because they can chain into each
other. The ones with more have to be
really freaking good to justify the
inclusion. Now, a lot of the best ones
here requires bunnies dying. So, sack
outlets, umbrellar, zealot seems
ridiculously good. But aside from this,
we have the typical package. Yeah, this
deck is fairly straightforward if you
are familiar with aristocrats. The only
difference is we need to make room for
24 hairs and a few cards that are broken
with them. We don't actually need to win
through attack. Draining is just so much
more efficient most of the time and
doesn't require us to wait a turn for
summoning sickness. Can't say I'm a
Universe versus Beyond fan if I haven't
flipped a Sephro. We don't have too much
room for utility unfortunately. A few
board wipes that work well with the
hairs and a spot removal to not auto
lose to certain cards. But yeah, we are
very much you do you, I do me, but
faster kind of deck. And here we have
another reason to play black, the mass
reanimation spells. They're actually so
efficient when your creatures are two
power and two mana value. Echoing return
is sweet here, but of course, throwming
stone. Now, you notice I haven't talked
much about the backside of Erdo because
two reasons. One, it's slow and probably
not happening often. Your opponents
aren't going to watch you cast the front
side, vomit your head onto the board,
and think, "Huh, I wonder what the
backside does. Maybe we should wait and
see." And the second reason is if you
flip it, you pretty much win on the spot
with just some basic setup. Just sack a
hair in response to the persist trigger.
Sack another, sack another. There are
also a ton of infinite combos you can do
with persist, but I decided against it.
Definitely an option though if you want.
And finally, the lens. We need excellent
mana fixing. Prioritizing white. I toss
in the cavern of souls in because we
don't want our commander countered.
Three tree city is going to be so much
fun here. And the only other lands that
need explaining are probably emergence
song and winding canyons. Yeah, if
possible, I want to go off at instant
speed holding up seven or eight mana at
the end of turn. Convoke into convoke
into convoke on tap transform. Erdo is
probably going to win a lot of games.
And there you have it. Erdo and Iselu.
The deck can definitely be described as
explosive. The commander being five mana
does slow things down a little bit. It's
fairly resilient though, especially if
you somehow get to flip to the backside.
But even without it, the typical
aristocrats deck will turn the board
into cards or at least a good chunk of
life drain if we get wiped. All
Aristocrat decks require a little bit of
practice to pilot. But don't worry, if
you're taking long enough, the table
will chime in to help you kill
themselves. budget is mid and it's
technically bracket two, but if you
wish, we can definitely make use of some
game changers like ancient tomb, maybe
even a meta vault to power out our
commander faster. Demonic tutor is
always good and I'd also love to try a
bola citadel. But yeah, Lorin Eclipse
looks great. I can't wait to try this
legend and many others from here. If you
enjoy this content, please like and
subscribe. I'll see you in the next
video.